y los equilibrios de nuestro continente
así como varios aspectos de nuestra vida
cotidiana ya han sido trastornados por
esta guerra y seguirán viviendo cambios
profundos en los próximos meses no se
dará relación será
difícil de ahora en adelante muchos
refugiados que vienen de ucrania serán
acogidos en nuestro continente
francia pondrá de su parte y desde ya
quiero agradecer a nuestras ciudades ya
nuestros pueblos que han comenzado a
ofrecer su ayuda a nuestras asociaciones
que también están trabajando por acoger
en las mejores condiciones a estos
refugiados nos estamos organizando y
acogeremos a todos los que lleguen a
nuestro suelo y los protegeremos francia
también hará su parte acogiendo a los
niños que se han visto obligados al
exilio y separados de sus padres debido
al combate y esto en colaboración
estrecha con las organizaciones no
gubernamentales que ya trabajan
en varios lugares de europa y en nuestro
país nuestra agricultura nuestra
industria muchos sectores económicos
sufren
y seguirán sufriendo ya sea porque
dependen de las materias primas
importadas de rusia o de ucrania o
porque exportan hacia de sus países
nuestro crecimiento que hoy es muy alta
se verá muy afectada el encarecimiento
del precio del petróleo del gas de las
materias primas tendrá y tiene y tendrá
consecuencias sobre nuestro poder de
compra el precio de la gasolina el
aumento del precio de la calefacción y
de algunos
productos
esto será fuerte
no tengo ninguna sino una brújula en
este conflicto protegerlos a todos
estamos protegiendo a los sectores
económicos más expuestos buscando nuevos
proveedores y nuevas salidas comerciales
por eso me he entrevistado con mis
homólogos de eeuu del medio oriente de
otras partes estamos buscando respuestas
adaptadas frente a la perturbación de
los flujos comerciales y al aumento de
los precios y le he pedido al primer
ministro que elabore para los próximos
días un plan de resiliencia económica y
social para responder a todas estas
dificultades
pero no debemos equivocarnos estos
acontecimientos no tendrán sólo
consecuencias inmediatas por las
próximas semanas son la señal de un
cambio de época de la guerra en europa
ya no le pertenece a nuestros libros de
historia y del colegio no está aquí ante
nuestros ojos como la democracia ya no
es considerada como un régimen les
indispensables los un libro que es el de
unos razón de profesión aquí
está siendo cuestionada ante nuestros
ojos lo mismo nuestra libertad y la de
nuestros hijos es un sistema de valentía
y un combate permanente a esta este
cambio brutal y trágico en la historia
tenemos que responder con decisiones
históricas nuestro país se ampliará
entonces la diversión de su defensa que
fue decía desde 2017 y continuará con su
estrategia de independencia y de
inversión en su economía su
investigación y su innovación campos que
ya fueron fortalecidos durante la
pandemia
europa lo está demostrando una
oportunidad notable y a partir de ahora
tiene que aceptar pagar el precio de la
paz de la libertad de la democracia debe
invertir cada vez más para depender
menos de los demás continentes y poder
decidir por sí misma en otras palabras
tendrá que convertirse en un poder en la
potencia más independiente y más
soberano potencia económica en primer
lugar ya no podemos depender de los
demás para alimentarnos cuida algunos
financiarnos por eso la prolongación de
las decisiones más fuertes durante la
pandemia en el plan de recuperación
europea paralelamente a esto vamos a
proponer un nuevo modelo económico
basado en la independencia y en el
progreso la potencia energética también
ya no podremos depender de los demás y
especialmente no podemos seguir
dependiendo del gas ruso para
desplazarnos y hacer funcionar nuestras
casas y nuestras fábricas libros por eso
después de haber decido para francia el
desarrollo de las energías renovables y
la construcción de nuevos reactores
nucleares defenderé una estrategia de
independencia energética europea
potencia de paz también donde por último
no podemos depender de los demás para
defendernos ya sea por tierra mar o aire
debajo del mar o en el aire en el
espacio en el ciberespacio
sobre este punto nuestra defensa europea
debe franquear una nueva era de decimos
no reunir a reunir el 10 y el 11
próximos en versalles a los jefes de
estado y de gobierno de europa durante
una cumbre que tendrá que decidir sobre
estos temas desde ya
nuestra europa ha mostrado unidad y
determinación
europa entró en una nueva era y tenemos
que seguir adelante
queridos compatriotas
marc la guerra en ucrania marca una
ruptura para nuestro continente y para
nuestras generaciones
sé cuánto les preocupa y esto es
elegirlo móviles nos moviliza a todos y
nos impondrá tomar decisiones a todos
yo les estaré informándoles de esta
guerra también trastorna nuestra vida
democrática y la campaña electoral que
se abre oficialmente a finales de esta
semana esta campaña permitirá un debate
democrático importante para la nación y
no romper fútbol pero este nudo no nos
impedirá reunirnos en torno a lo
esencial de work institute sé que puedo
contar cuando estés para el libro su
apego a la libertad de judith a la
igualdad a la fusión a la fraternidad
para aplastar a fons en un lugar de
francia en el mundo herramiento el tifón
nunca dejaré de defenderlos y llevar en
alto su nombre en el número de ustedes
viva la república viva francia